have you learned the lizzle dance i have  this is huge about downtown have you  tried it okay i have i've yeah  it's i haven't put a minute  i think you should try it okay it's it's  yes okay do we have the video of lizzo  doing it how about this how about this  okay before we leave you because we're  about to go before we leave you today we  need to show you some of our favorite  stars doing their best take on that  dance let me just say lizzo enjoy  joining us band dnce really set the tone  for blake shelton uh sangeeta how are  you at the dance  i was pretty good i don't know i don't  even know if you're doing the right  moves did anybody  did  [Laughter]  man a woman to pump me up feeling fussy  walking in my valencia seas trying to  bring out the fabulous cause i  wait so much i'ma need like two shots in  my club it's about time in a minute i'ma  need  [Music]  i'ma need a sentimental man a woman to  pump me up feeling fussy walking in my  valencia season